[Music]
in cyber flashing news show you a titty
on a button oh not so much submitted by
Junior MAFIA
hmm sending unsolicited dick pics is now
illegal in Texas yeah so everything's
bigger in Texas
so that means if y'all want to get at
all the trolls that send you dick fit
pigs or whatever just fly over to Texas
and then open them up and start
reporting them don't think eyes have to
be from Texas for the laws you have to
open it in Texas how do you know I'm
just trying to help you out catch these
criminals yeah I wonder what the rules
dare they do this to those good men who
are just trying to take pictures of
dickin and share with people they're
giving you their most private
possessions yeah if it's been like a
week since I've seen him like if he was
away on a trip I'll take a dick pic cuz
you like you would take it oh you mean
would receive it okay I'll take what
like it's not my first choice of picture
to get but like if he's been away for a
while and the hormones are raging I'll
take one
really yeah good to know never some
perfect solicited no son no you know
that is a really good conversation to
have I realized a lot of men especially
when in a relationship have no idea that
their their girl their woman would even
want a dick they're never thought of it
yeah I had this conversation and it only
happened in a situation like this where
a bunch of my friends were talking about
it and my man's was there and I was like
yeah like I would like a dick pic I mean
I asked for one he was like what and I
was like well I think there had been
situations where I where I had and he
just truly didn't think that you're
being serious yeah that's fun all I hear
that and you were joking no just like oh
I know she's saying it but it wasn't
you know why it's cuz it sending sending
dick pics is a pre relationship thing
it's like I'm trying to get her in post
relationship yeah is like err no really
like talking like you know you're
interested in each other it's primal
though yeah yeah like that's what I'm
saying is though like if I ask for one
pre-dating no no like like you're
already in the early stages you're not
like really in it like
boyfriend-girlfriend yet but like you're
still your sexual or you're shopping
around feel like I'm actually [ __ ]
you a bunch if we're in that route that
time in the relationship we're having
sex like a lot right so what I need to
get what if I'm trying to move out of
the friendzone so I send you a dictate
I'd be like that's not how you move out
I'm like oh you got to yell out of the
friendzone into the creeper zone to move
out of the friendzone [ __ ]
to the jail zone I see dick pics and
unsolicited videos oh no I was talking
to do you think she's gonna [ __ ] love
this they have no self-awareness and I'm
like we can have this conversation you
could ask me like do you want and if I'm
like blue at least it's like a Tuesday
morning he's like I miss you baby and
there was no sexting it was him this guy
who I was seeing back in Chicago who was
like I think about you every single day
and masturbate to you and I was like
cool like that's that's a compliment
whatever and then it was just like wow
here's this video not like oh but we had
been prior to that this was like two
years after we stopped seeing each other
Oh prior to that like we had been seeing
each other again he never sent a dick
pic while we were saying I miss you
that's what he's doing
yeah like I miss you but let you live in
a different place and also he ended up
like having a wife so it's like I don't
want to talk to you most fun Wow
and I was like can you if I said if you
and your wife do not have an agreement
of an open relationship you
cannot speak to me anymore especially
not like this that's weird
yes I had to cut that off if you do have
an O I'm gonna greement you'd be down to
like back on yeah sure I mean I would
like it if he could come see me could
have come seen me cuz I don't want to
just have like a pen pal a comp al
yeah that's such a waste of time right
and my own have time I want a pen pal
you people don't agree with me about
this not liking sexting thing because we
were talking about on hey [ __ ] and I
was like I don't sex cuz it doesn't do
anything for me like well I mean I don't
like it long-term like I can do it for a
week or so I mean we could hang out on
Friday but like not for months I don't
want to be like and I'm touching my
[ __ ] to be like and then I'm yeah it's
so so extra yeah yes so Texas here
they're saying that you can get a $500
fine oh that's not enough to stop the
day a criminal record oh if you're in
Texas and you send in unsolicited dick
pic so this this new law came into force
after a campaign by the dating app
Bumble which is a feminist dating app
apparently reject oh it's cause the
girls ask the guys is that what it is
yeah you initiate conversation Oh like
you make the first move
so then guys join in and they're just
like I hope someone hits me up yeah so
you match with people too so it's not
just like imagine people and then she
decides if she wants to ask that's
actually like what what what dating caps
look like like what is tinder like why
don't you just sign up with a fake
profile yeah
TIFF I'll let you know there it is
borrow your app and leave let me look
through it scroll through it yeah cuz I
was like cuz I was considering just
being like should I just make a fake
account I just see what is what's up in
there you can't I actually tried you
can't make a fake one because like you
have to actually have a picture with
like an actual face cuz the bots like if
you try to put a picture of nothing
it'll like or what if you pick someone
else's face no remember pokeyman she
like what her fate hurt like she tried
to sign up and then it got flagged as
being fake because they couldn't believe
that she would actually
she tried to attach me Instagram to it
somebody used Nikki space for one that's
a fan sent to us I don't use my face too
and I'm like can I borrow the app like
you definitely can do fake though
because this dude who I matched with
like two years ago on bumble ended up
being this guy who I ended up seeing on
Instagram with like a hundred million
followers I'm like oh that's then I
confronted him he sent me this dick pic
that looked like like who knows me look
at my day like this and like you could
tell this is fake
wakie that he had added a dick on top of
the day she got a dildo and you put it
shut the dick photo shows like a black
man like that's not real and then I said
like look again I'm not into having a
penpal if you want to meet up let's meet
up yesterday yeah and then he just was
like never saying that we would meet up
this only lasted like two days because
when I found dude on Instagram I was
like here's the thing this is not you
mm-hmm did you report him I don't
remember I think I reported his profile
that his profile was you trying to
catfish wasting people's time I was
thinking like he stuffs a [ __ ]
12-inch dildo on his pants and he's like
he ought maybe I can pass an awfully
know so he's trying to basically like
yeah tit for tat haven't thought even in
that way for so long that I did not know
you'll never get my nudes
I want you nude so you get a Polaroid
picture wait do you not send him nude
she doesn't give me [ __ ] I'm terrified
of them of any one of them leaking ever
neck down what I was yeah what about
that no nothing that would recognize
like that could pinpoint it was you I
don't know I feel like if they hacked
into his phone I would know Boni my
phone first of all has nothing before
Zuri but in it yeah exactly so they
could match it they could match it this
is the same girl I have too many like
birthmarks and tattoos that I'd be [ __ ]
yeah yeah I don't have tattoos but I do
have like you know certain scars and
like model mosquito bites
you don't identify identify but I said
he could have a Polaroid picture nude
picture of me because that liked it out
can't hack that you could take a picture
of the picture no he said he would take
a picture a picture say no I wouldn't do
that you're getting it you're never
getting it I would've been this far I
wouldn't do what about videos like you
like these videos no you gotta get
projector slides projectors I need a
[ __ ] super aid like she'll put it
into that and that's where he could view
it but no she's talking about the one
where you thats all you can possibly get
the only thing that you can't put your
phone up to and take a pic exact yeah
only your eyeball you know you could
project it you could use some sort of
projection you live in a cynical world
it's a cynical time because one time I
took a picture of the moon through a
telescope on my phone yeah in a video
yeah I put it on my story dude North
Korean soldiers yeah no not soldiers but
the room North Korean farmers just right
across them oh they're all actors
it was just Bobby Lee I know it was
Bobby P yeah I looked at Saturn through
a telescope and that [ __ ] freak me the
[ __ ] it's crazy and that crazy I'm I
can't believe this shit's real that's
far away it's scary looks on the ring
yeah they could have rigged it the
government's crazy balls yeah that's
true they could have put a slide in
there of a planet that's all try to be
more skeptical wait so do you guys think
that this unsolicited pic rule is good
yes yeah because if they were a repeat
offender let's say you know five hundred
dollars is for a one okay whatever but
like if they hit up ten girls alone
solicited dick pics that's five thousand
dollars do you think people are gonna
try and fight and be like that's not my
dick yeah and then you have to go and
prove yourself yeah because they're also
saying that this could this could be
through text through email through
airdrop now there are messenger it's all
illegal and what if it's like egg stuff
like what if exes get angry and income
back after with it yeah see okay this is
where we are though right now in the
world like people are overcompensating
for things people are abusing these
things or people are not believing
victims or people and so it's like we I
think we're gonna get to a place where
people think so much more before they do
[ __ ] or say [ __ ] because of this stage
they're in right now where everyone's
like overcompensating you feel like you
can't say anything like comedians can't
be funny anymore because people are
forced to think before they speak and
then I hope well there's my hope needs
Jesus when you have technology watching
you
[Music]